English spelling is really hard to learn.
Because history.
The examples that are usually used to demonstrate
that are things like
the o-u-g-h words: cough, through, dough,
and so on.
But there are other reasons too, and one of
them involves this.
It’s a character so important to English
that it has its own name:
“schwa”.
To explain it, let’s start by talking about
this letter.
What does that sound like?
In school, we’re taught the name of it,
/eɪ/.
And, sure, it can sound like that,
in words like “later”.
But you’re actually making two separate
vowel sounds there:
/eɪ/.
“Later”.
Sometimes kids are taught this letter
as just /æ/.
And it can sound like that too,
in words like “cash”.
But it can also be the /ɔː/ in “call”.
And depending on your accent,
and I’ve got to sound really posh
to make this work,
it could also be the /ɑ/ in “bath”.
That’s really at the back of the mouth,
it sounds completely unnatural for me.
But! This letter can also sound
like the /ə/ in “about”.
And that sound, /ə/, is the one
we’re interested in here.
Linguists have a chart, part of the International
Phonetic Alphabet, to talk about vowel sounds:
and it goes all the way from a vowel like /i/,
which is produced with the highest bit of
your tongue near the front of your mouth,
tongue really close to the roof,
to /ɑ/, highest bit of the tongue at
the back, not close to the roof.
/i…ɑ/.
If you study linguistics, then your first
few lessons of phonetics are basically just
a group of people all making
the same weird sounds
and then trying to understand what the bits
of their mouth are actually doing.
Someone usually tries to poke around to feel
where their tongue is
and nearly makes themselves throw up.
Anyway, sitting right in the middle of that
chart is that /ə/ from “about”.
Represented by the “schwa”.
It is central, everything just kind of sitting
in the middle,
it’s the vowel that requires the least effort.
/ə/ is the vowel you use when you’ve got
to make a sound but don’t know what to say.
“Uhh…”
So yes, schwa is the A in “about”,
but it's also the E in “petition”.
The last I in “definite”.
The first O in “potato”.
And the U in “support”.
I said English spelling was a mess.
No wonder that “definate” with an A is
such a common misspelling:
if you don’t know that it has
the same root as ‘finite’,
it’s fair to think that it’s spelled that way.
That schwa sound, defin-uh-t gives you very
little information about what letters to use.
So what’s the difference between
those two words?
Well, in “finite”, there’s
stress on “nite”.
But in “definite” we don’t stress that
syllable anymore, so it gets reduced.
Meaning that its vowel gets reduced to schwa,
the least-effort vowel sound.
Every vowel letter in English, A, E, I, O, U,
is capable of being reduced to schwa.
Not always, but they’re capable of it.
Sometimes, vowels like that
are reduced so much
that they disappear entirely,
in words like these.
Your dialect may be different, of course,
and if you pronounce the words on their own,
there may still be something there.
But give me a story to read out about a
“sep’rate choc’late cam’ra”,
and there’s no schwa in the middle
of any of those.
Vowels get reduced even further in quickly-spoken,
slurred sentences.
So, the formal way to pronounce
this sentence would be:
“I’m Going To Go To The Store.”
But in real life, in my accent,
if I was just saying that to a friend as I
was headed out the house,
I’d reduce it to something like:
/ə̃mə̃nəgʌʔɾəðə stɔː/
Almost every vowel in there was schwa.
[at half speed]
/ə̃mə̃nəgʌʔɾəðə stɔː/
There was a bit of stress on ‘go’,
a bit of effort went in there.
And “store” couldn’t get reduced to
/stə/.
But other than that, it was all schwa.
“I’m Going To” was reduced to /ə̃mə̃nə/.
American speakers might reduce it differently
to either /a͡imə/ or /əmə/.
That’s not lazy, that’s not wrong, that’s
just how language works.
We all convert between those reduced vowels
and fully-spelled-out words instinctively,
although it’s something that people learning
English aren’t always taught:
they often have to pick it up by themselves.
And that’s one of the reasons why,
when occasionally, when you get these
well-meaning spelling reformers who say
“well, every word should just be spelled
how it sounds”,
they haven’t thought it through.
There are loads of English words that have
more than one pronunciation:
not just because of accent,
but because most of the time,
we reduce the vowels to schwa.
Thanks to my co-authors,
Molly Ruhl and Gretchen McCulloch.
Gretchen has a great podcast called Lingthusiasm,
the link is in the description.